After my divorce hearing, where I was married for 10 years,
I was a traditional wife.
I was a stay at home mother to four children.
One of them is disabled.
She had four open heart surgeries.
I have been their primary parent
since the moment they entered this universal realm.
I'm the person that they have known from sun up to sun down
and through the night.
They do have two parents,
but the way our family was structured,
I was the one that took care of them.
He was a little bit busy doing other things.
I wrongfully assumed that courts would
see the situation for what it was
and give me everything that I wanted
and I would be able to remain their primary parent
and remain in goods.
Like just everything would be amazing.
And that's not what happened.
I had to not only split custody, but in my.
In my opinion,
it was horrible because this person doesn't even have their own home.
He is living with his romantic partner.
So I was like, how is the court gonna give you 50% custody?
You don't even have a fucking home.
You're an actual hobo. Sexual.
You have no home,
no job, nothing.
There's no way a court is gonna give you 50% custody.
They sure as fuck did.
Not only did they,
they awarded him child support
because he quit his job right before the divorce hearing
to throw off our income.
And then the Court used a really fucked up calculation for my income,
and it was just, like,
literally the worst of the worst of the worst.
My attorney said her jaw was on the floor.
She has never had a divorce end up so lopsided
in her whole fucking career.
And then she wished me luck, and I was on my way.
If I didn't have the money to pay her.
Sucks to suck.
In the franticness of like,
oh, my god,
I have to give this person some.
I'm gonna be homeless.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, how am I gonna pay child support and pay my rent and all my bills
when I'm barely making it by myself?
Needless to say,
it's been five years.
I never went homeless.
I never lost anything,
I never lost my kids,
and I've only gotten stronger and better.
And it was because in the franticness after that,
I called an attorney, thinking,
somebody has to fix this.
Somebody's gonna make it better.
And I called an attorney.
I told him the whole story,
and he was like,
do you want me to tell you the real fucking truth?
Talk to you like you're my fucking sister?
Or do you want me to give you, like,
the polite answer?
Like, he could hear the vulnerability and the. The.
The desperation in my voice.
He was like, get the fuck over it.
Divorces suck.
People get bad results,
and if you continue to Try to fight with him in the courts,
you're only gonna make yourself look worse.
You can be angry,
you can be mad,
but you need to just shut the fuck up,
put your head down, and focus on your life with your kids.
Because the longer you sit in that anger
about how it didn't go your way,
your pot, you're stopping yourself.
You're slowing down your healing, your.
Yeah, you're slowing down your healing.
It was like a light clicked in my head.
Like, you're right.
It's over. The divorce is over.
The decisions have been made.
I can either accept it and move forward and focus on my life
and focus on solutions
and focus on. At least I don't have this ugly, fucking dusty in my bed,
in my body, in my anything anymore.
And that's what I did.
And life got better.
The minute you stop looking at all the problems
and start thinking of solutions,
everything starts to get better.